[Music]
thank you
it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
our top story a new offer to hundreds of
thousands of NHS staff which could end
strikes by nurses and ambulance workers
I'm delighted that the government has
reached agreement with unions
representing over a million NHS workers
on a fair and reasonable pay settlement
health workers can now decide between
taking further strike action and picking
up an offer
also tonight violence erupts in Paris
after president macro attempts to push
through pension reforms without a vote
more Bank turmoil as the First Republic
Bank in the U.S is rescued with a 30
billion dollar
the Pentagon releases a video of a
Russian jet releasing fuel on a U.S
drone calling it a reckless interception
the social media app Tick Tock has been
banned on all government devices
and Sky News analysis can reveal the
councils spending more on paying bank
loans than on services
plus we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages that's in our
press preview from 10 30.
[Music]
hello there good evening after a winter
of strikes right across the NHS a deal
has been done between the government and
14 unions which could see the end of
strike action the Prime Minister has
said he's pleased they've come to a
settlement which is fair and affordable
workers including nurses and ambulance
staff are now due to vote on the offer
and are being encouraged by union
leaders to vote in favor of it just one
union says it will not be making a
recommendation to its members Skies
Matthew Thompson has this report
it's been a winter of widespread
disruption in the NHS staff from Porters
to nurses physios to ambulance workers
angered by their wages and conditions
and after nearly 20 000 canceled
operations and months of strikes a
breakthrough I'm delighted that the
government has reached agreement with
unions representing over a million NHS
workers on a fair and reasonable pay
settlement this agreement rightly
recognizes the Fantastic work that our
NHS workers like nurses midwives and
paramedics do whilst also being
affordable for the taxpayer the Royal
College of Nursing initially demanded a
pay increase of 19 this deal Falls some
way short of that with an initial
one-off payment of two percent in
addition to the pay review bodies
recommendation of at least a four
percent salary increase there will also
be a five percent increase in wages next
year
while the lowest paid workers will
receive a 10.4 percent bump bringing
them in line with the national living
wage
unions admit the offer is lower than
initial expectations now they must
convince their members to vote for it
hers can now decide be between taking
further strike action and picking up an
offer I know that you know me and other
trade unions work together to uh to
engage with the government and press for
as much money as we could one of the key
outstanding questions though is where
this money comes from there was no part
announced in the budget the health
secretary has been clear that it won't
come from patient funding but if it is
to be fine from somewhere else in the
NHS budget well then what has to be cut
to pay for it and there are no
guarantees that union members will
accept Burt is an oncology nurse and
says the offer isn't enough to make up
for the increase in pressure and
decrease in conditions personally I
would say say no to this offer because I
don't think it's it's up it's an offer
that come towards the challenges that we
have within the NHS
and I'm I'm ready to step up and strike
again
tens of thousands of NHS workers voted
to strike for better pay no they must
decide if the offer is good enough
but with Junior doctors still to start
their own negotiations with the
government the threat of yet more
walkouts hasn't gone away Matthew
Thompson Sky News
well our political correspondent Liz
Bates is at the Department of Health so
progress for health unions it seems Liz
but does this deal have any impact on
the other strikes and negotiations
currently ongoing
well I think that's the big question I
have to say first of all this does feel
like it could be a real breakthrough
moment started I think by the union
suspending strikes coming back to the
table the government in the end as well
moving quite substantially on pay worth
saying as well in Scotland a similar pay
deal has been reached unions there
representing NHS and ambulance workers
have accepted a pay deal there which
would give their workers an average of
6.5 pay increase this year into next
year your question will it have a domino
effect on the many other industrial
disputes that are going on junior
doctors of course teachers transport
workers and many others well there are
still obstacles in the way not least of
course is the money there to
um to to fund pay offers across all of
those different sectors and on the other
side is there a willingness among union
bosses to suspend strikes to progress
talks that is what the government is
saying they need to do but look I think
there will be real pressure now on both
sides to recreate what has happened
today but I think they will also be
encouraged by the deals that we've seen
because I think it's fair to say that
after months of stalemate this is a huge
step forward
Liz thank you
thousands of people have come out onto
the streets of Paris to protest pension
reforms being pushed through Parliament
without a vote tear gas and water cannon
have been used by police in the French
Capital tonight to try to disperse the
crowds our International correspondent
John Sparks reports
these are the scenes tonight in the
heart of the French capital
with French riot police being pelted
with cobblestones responding with tear
gas and water cannon
[Music]
La Place de la Concorde not living up to
its name
[Applause]
in France you meddle with a retirement
age at your peril as president macron is
learning to his cost
try to make the French wait another two
years for retirement has produced a
furious reaction
bringing thousands out onto the streets
protesting across the river from the
French National Assembly
[Music]
inside if there was more pandemonium
MPS were in a Rowdy mood as the Prime
Minister walked to the podium
jeering her and waving signs against the
plans to change the retirement age
and singing the national anthem
[Applause]
Elizabeth born fought to be heard as she
announced the government would be
forcing the changes through Parliament
without a vote
the government has for now Advance its
controversial plans but at a huge cost
and exposed their enormous unpopularity
giving a boost to opposition politicians
like far-right leader Marine Le Pen it's
an acknowledgment of total failure for
Emmanuel macron because it's his reform
he is the one who carried it it was even
the only one he defended during the
presidential campaign so it's his
personal failure
France has for weeks now been living
through strikes rubbish has been left to
rot uncollected on the streets and huge
protests have gathered momentum that
unrest now looks likely to intensify
Dominic wagorn Sky News
America's largest banks have tonight
stepped in with a 30 billion dollar
rescue package to shore up First
Republic Bank stocks on Wall Street
rallied on the news which followed
turmoil in the banking sector starting
with a run on Silicon Valley Bank last
week our U.S postponent Mark Stone joins
us now live from Washington so two Banks
down already in the states Mark and now
this big effort to prop up a third what
is the significance of this
yeah it's undoubtedly very significant
and it's I think it's fair to say that
here at the U.S treasury Department
there is there is nervousness this is
the the latest very uncomfortable moment
for the banking sector not just here but
across Europe we saw what happened to
Credit Suisse being bailed out by the uh
The Regulators or the um uh the
officials in Switzerland uh just this
morning well now this extraordinary move
by the big banking Giants of the United
States the likes of Bank of America
Citigroup JP Morgan Chase Wells Fargo
Goldman Sachs and others clubbing
together to inject uh uninsured deposits
amounting to some 30 billion dollars
into First Republic Bank a medium-sized
Bank uh caters for a niche group of
people rather like those other two that
went down trying to prop this Bank up
now in a statement a joint statement by
this bank they said um this action by
America's largest banks reflects their
confidence in First Republic and in
banks of all sizes then it demonstrates
their overall commitment to helping
Banks serve their customers and
communities Regional mid-size and small
banks are critical to the health and
functioning of our financial system not
a joint statement by the banks that have
injected this money look I think on the
face of it this is clearly about
restoring confidence in the back banking
sector restoring confidence in those
smaller less well-known banks that are
having difficulty at the moment it is
also clearly about self-preservation
because if there is a lack of confidence
and that is the the Bedrock of the
banking system confidence then those
larger Banks could feel that they might
be threatened as well so it's about
self-preservation and it is about
restoring confidence in the banking
system but the very Act of having to do
that could spook things um I I would say
that though that tonight as Wall Street
closed uh it was up and I think that
certainly is a good sign but these are
unnerving times let's say
Mark at the U.S treasury thank you
unsafe and unprofessional the words from
the Pentagon which has tonight defended
the release of Declassified footage
showing a Russian jet dumping fuel on a
U.S drone over the Black Sea the
incident on Tuesday has heightened
tensions between the White House and the
Kremlin with suggestions that although
the interception by the Russian plane
seemed intentional the Downing of the
Drone was a reckless mistake Sky's U.S
correspondent James Matthews has more
high above the Black Sea this was the
moment of contact a Russian jet dumps
fuel as it approaches an unmanned U.S
surveillance drone the Pentagon says
this was an effort to take it down
having filled once there's another
attempt
this time the footage from the onboard
camera cuts out the Americans say
because the Russian aircraft connected
with the propeller ultimately the
Russian military and Russian government
is responsible for its own behavior and
when that behavior is unsafe and
unprofessional we're going to call it
out as we've done in this case
the Russians dispute the U.S version of
events surrounding its MQ-9 Reaper drone
stating the Russian aircraft made no
contact with the Drone and that it came
down after attempting a sharp maneuver
the tail of the tape suggests
differently after one fly past the Drone
propeller appears intact and operational
following another one of the blades is
bent dumping fuel around it seems to be
an effort to stop the engine of the
Drone working then they were trying to
come up from behind and then use their
aerodynamics to push the fuel into the
engine and then frankly it was military
incompetence that led to them getting a
bit too close and actually hitting the
Drone itself
this Reaper drone incident is the first
military contact between the U.S and
Russia since the Ukraine war started the
risk is that Russia deliberately does it
again that they want to escalate this to
look like a U.S Russia conflict so they
may try to do more things that would
draw a U.S response
U.S officials say they're unsure if this
Collision was deliberate or accidental
but insist they'll continue to fly
drones in international airspace therein
lies a test of Russian intentions
James Matthews Sky News Washington
the Russian invasion of Ukraine has
created instability across the region
for Moldova which borders Ukraine the
security threat is much greater the
foreign secretary James cleverley who is
in Moldova today has pledged 10 million
pounds to help the country well last
month moldova's pro-western president
accused Russia of attempting to Stage a
coup which Russia has denied one source
of tension has been the Breakaway
Republic of transnistria which has been
under Russian military control since the
1990s well neither Moldova nor The Wider
International Community recognize its
independence our Europe correspondent
Siobhan Robbins has been to the
contested border between Moldova and
transnistria and sent this report
on the edge of Europe a pocket of
pro-russian support
this is transnistria a breakaway region
in eastern Moldova politically
economically and militarily supported by
Moscow
here the hammer and sickle flutters in
the wind as public opinion favors the
east
transnistria and Russia are one
structure and they have to be United
Andre says
the Russian troops here are our
guarantee of safety while they're here
we are safe this young woman adds
under the Gaze of Soviet icons here it's
Ukraine that's been eyed with suspicion
recently accused of plotting to kill
their separatist leader something it
denies
a few miles away in pro-western Moldova
allegiances are very different
and transnistria local mayor ludmiller
says they're feeling nervous of their
neighbors
I believe they have a big base of World
War II weapons and this is our biggest
fear she tells me we hope they won't
come here with their weapons because
Moldova has a small army
Moldova is in the middle of a kind of
political tug of war with the Russians
trying to exploit divisions of the past
and the government here trying to keep
everyone together
Russia's been accused of stirring up
unrest at anti-government protests and
spreading propaganda to weaken Ukraine's
allies
in moldova's capital the UK foreign
secretary came with a message for
support and 10 million pounds to help
fight Russian interference How likely is
it do you think that Moldova could be
Russia's next Target and what's your
message to President Putin moldova's
been doing all the right things
but in his arrogance Putin has attempted
to punish Moldova for doing those right
things and it is incumbent upon the UK
and our friends and allies across the
Europe European continent to support the
doc Moldova as it continues on that
Progressive journey in the right
direction
ministers don't expect Russian tanks to
roll across this border anytime soon but
make no mistake they are fighting a war
a battle against disinformation and
disruption aimed at spreading fear and
unrest
Siobhan Robbins Sky News Moldova
Tick Tock for many is considered a
social media platform for young people
but today it was the focus of a debate
in Parliament the government has banned
Tick Tock from UK government phones over
security concerns around the Chinese
owned video app Sky Science and
Technology editor Tom Clark reports hi
there was a time when government
embraced Tick-Tock I want to say thank
you for staying at home it's easily the
most popular social media app amongst
young people the UK is passing some new
legislation to make the internet safer
for the younger generation and what
better way to get liked among millions
of them we dispatched an anthropomorphic
porcine Ambassador now tick tock's ban
from government phones we know that
there is already limited use of tick
tock across government but it is also
good cyber hygiene the main reason
tiktok's parent company bike dance is
Chinese tiktok's ability to act as a
data trojan horse is Gravely concerning
and tackling techno authoritarianism
must be one of of our foremost
priorities so Tick Tock is too risky for
ministers and officials to have on their
government-issued devices but of all the
apps on our phones it's arguably no
worse than other ones when it comes to
the amount of personal information it
has it knows who we are where we are
what device we're using even our
contacts and the content of our messages
but so too to other apps like Instagram
Facebook and YouTube the key question
with Tick Tock is actually more about
whether or not if the Chinese government
were to ask tiktok to turn over its data
whether Tick Tock would be able or
legally able to refuse that request try
telling them that today Net Zero
secretary Grant shapes posted on Tick
Tock that he'd continue using it on his
personal device and it's not clear if
the ban will have any impact on millions
of UK tiktok users I'm not leaving
the company today said it was
disappointed by the decision saying it
believes government bans in the EU the
US and now here are based on fundamental
misconceptions driven by wider
geopolitics
but is it just the beginning the Biden
Administration has threatened an
outright ban on Tick Tock unless it
sheds Chinese ownership
the UK has stopped short of that but can
the world's most popular video reel app
persuade the West to keep on swiping or
is trust ebbing away Tom Clark Sky News
a major Wind Farm developer has told Sky
News the Chancellor's budget yesterday
has made a new multi-billion pound
project scheduled to be built in the UK
challenging Jeremy Hunt has been
criticized after he failed to mention
any significant funding for the
renewable energy Industries our climate
change and energy correspondent Hannah
Thomas Peter reports the UK's wind power
industry is feeling squeezed with
soaring costs and limited tax incentives
it was hoping the budget would provide a
comprehensive lift but that didn't
happen
now major Wind Farm developer orstead is
questioning whether horns E3 its largest
project yet can even go ahead we were
really hoping that we would see a
response to what we and other project
owners had been looking for from the
chancellor and his Focus his efforts on
other areas
um it's a real disappointment it
certainly makes it challenging we've
been very clear that this is a project
that brings fantastic jobs through
construction and through Decades of
operations and we really want to make
sure we can realize that but the
chancellor is certainly not made that
easier it is a stark warning from a
critical industry player horns E3 here's
the planned location about 75 miles off
the Norfolk Coast is due to begin
production in 2026 if it goes ahead the
8 billion pound project would be the
biggest wind farm in the world with
around 230 wind turbines generating
enough electricity to power more than 3
million homes projects like this are
crucial to the government's Ambitions to
deliver a five-fold increase in offshore
wind power by the end of the decade
making the problem worse Fierce
competition from America and Europe both
agreeing to substantial subsidy packages
in the global race to become a clean
energy superpower we're one of the
largest investors in UK infrastructure
generating jobs right across the country
but I think we can't really take that
position for granted it's not just us
now Leading The Way with minimal
competition from abroad other countries
are really hot on our heels the
government is due to set out further
measures to incentivize investment in
the nation's renewable Industries
Industries now looking for reassurance
that the UK after leading on wind for so
long isn't about to start falling behind
Hannah Thomas Peter Sky News
money is tied across the public sector
but perhaps nowhere more so than in
local government Skinny's analysis has
found evidence of the financial Straits
which some local councils find
themselves in with two in Surrey
spending more on debt interest and
paying back loans than they do on
providing local services such as
transport and social care here's our
data and forensics correspondent Tom
Cheshire with the second of three
reports into how our councils are faring
in the cost of living crisis
Nottingham Castle was built nearly a
thousand years ago as an impregnable
Norman Fortress even as a tourist
attraction though it's just as
inaccessible owned by the council it's
been closed since November when its
trust went into liquidation
the castle is a symbol of a city and of
a council that struggled financially in
the two years since it lost 38 million
pounds on a failed company Robin Hood
energy
that's meant cuts to vital services like
base 51 a youth center just around the
corner from the castle which has only
six months left in this property unless
it gets more funding before I started
coming here I was going out getting into
trouble
but since I started coming here the
office counseling and
obviously that's hoping got onto a
better path for one here I'll be getting
through everyday basically I'd probably
get arrested by now Nottingham was
forced to issue what's known as a
section 114 notice an official
Declaration of financial distress it's
not the only one Slough thoric Croydon
have done the same within the last year
and woking has warned it might have to
as well
the notices have come as councils
receive much less funding from central
government this shows the decline over
the last eight years a nearly 90 percent
drop
councils have had to find money
elsewhere Sky News analysis reveals that
some are now spending more on servicing
debt than they are on providing services
spellthorne for instance spends more
than one and a half times more although
the council told us the income from
their Investments outweighs the debt
working in Surrey has racked up nearly 2
billion pounds in debt investing in
property developments like this and it's
in danger of running out of cash
you might ask why a commuter town like
woking needs a Skyline like Singapore
but these towers are the products of a
system whose demands whose incentives
have changed with less funding from
central government councils were urged
to find new revenue streams councils
were told to be Innovative
entrepreneurial it's act like any other
company and this involved Investments
property other sort of Investments maybe
outside their own local Authority area
Nottingham City Council also told us
that because they're receiving less
money in government grants they're
cutting services they would prefer not
to including funding the base 51 Youth
Center
but the council also made a terrible bet
on Robinhood energy for which they
deserve blame so does the funding system
that incentivizes those bets Tom
Cheshire Sky News Nottingham
well if you scan this QR code on your
screen you can find out how much your
local Authority spends on financing debt
or you can go straight to the data and
forensics section of the Sky News
website